okay wonderful
okay um hi everyone i
i
like to welcome you to the simons
institute theoretically speaking series
and today is the lecture on monitoring
people and their vital signs using radio
signals and machine learning by dina
katabi from mit
and before we get started i just want to
go over how you can ask questions in the
event
so we have people here at calvin lab and
remotely on zoom
a and people here obviously can just
raise their uh hands and people on zoom
can ask questions using the q a at the
bottom of the control panel
and
i guess dina if she notices
a
during the talk she might answer but
really we have reserved 10 minutes
at the end of the talk for the q a
uh so i guess i should introduce myself
i'm shafi golosa i'm the director of
simon's institute
uh this is an institute for theory of
computing
and uh it's a place to convene uh um
theoreticians in in the joint fields uh
applied people people in other fields
like biology physics neuroscience and so
forth
and uh
especially young scholars uh trying to
train them and
welcome them into the community
and uh
[Music]
we um
it's very important for us as a mission
is to expand our horizons from the sort
of narrow theory field to fields
outside and to beautiful achievements
from outside the theory group
or the theory
topic and today's lecture is a really
testimony of that in
it's open to the white public a
and um
our speaker is going to be uh dina
katabi who's uh thrawn and nicole femme
professor of electrical engineering and
computing uh computer science at mit and
she's a macarthur fellow
and a member of the national academy of
engineering she's a leader of the
network group at mit a part of the
computer science in a artificial lab an
artificial intelligence lab and a
director of the mit center for wireless
networks in mobile computing
and she received her phd and master's
degree from mit
in 2003 in 1999 so she's a real
i guess mit and my dear and their
bachelor from the university of uh
damascus in 1995
five and a research interest span lots
of topics mobile systems machine
learning health internet of things
wireless networks and she's also worked
on compressed sensing there's a she's a
lot of very beautiful uh papers that
actually touch uh
algorithms and uh and complexity theory
and uh
she has received multiple prestigious
awards including the acm prize in
computing the acm grace mary hopper
award two sig com tests of time awards
the sloan fellowship the ieee
communication society
uh william and bennett prize and
multiple best paper awards as well as
the macarthur award
and she's also sponsored
startup from her lab
and she has her own
startup as well so please welcome
dina katabi i'm extremely excited uh to
hear her lecture and i'm grateful that
she was willing to come and tell us
about her work please do not take it
away
thanks jeffy
hi everyone i'm so excited to be here
and to present to you
so i'm going to tell you about uh some
of my recent work about using the
combination of radio signals and machine
learning too much for people and their
health
so
should i do something should i speak
louder
a tiny bit
okay
so yeah so as i said like i work on the
intersection of radio signal and machine
learning
and uh one of the things that really uh
excites me and
about radio signals in particular if you
think about it we are all living in in
the sea of radio signals
and these radio signals bounce off our
bodies
and uh when they bounce off your body
they actually get modulated by your
physiological signals by your breathing
by even the pulsing of your blood uh the
twitching of your muscles even like the
small eye muscles here uh when any
movement that you do actually leaves a
trace on the radio signals around you
and a natural question to ask is can we
decode that information from the radio
signal can we just analyze those radio
signals that bounce off your body and
from that can tell so much about your
health so this is exactly the question
that occupied me and my research group
at mit so we started thinking and
working on uh this
new project that was new to us like
eight years ago and when we started
looking into it but basically can we
design a box that looks very much like
your wi-fi box at home but it's much
smarter instead of just purely sitting
there and being just your wi-fi box we
are going to analyze these radio signals
and we are going to get from that your
sleep your breathing your gait your
heartbeat uh your interaction with other
people
and
when we started it was just a question
can we do it and over time we discovered
indeed that we can do it and we
developed this box that we call it the
emerald box and one of the reason why we
can do this is actually the ability to
analyze radio signals using advanced and
customized machine learning model and in
this talk i'm going to show you what we
can do with this kind of method and what
kind of signals and information we can
get about people so let me start with uh
just an illustration so radio signal
spread in the environment they reflect
off our bodies because our bodies are
full of water
and some of these reflections come back
to our device which analyzes them using
machine learning here in this case it
will detect a4 and can alert the
caregiver via text email or phone call
so so this is just an illustration now
let's see what we can get with real
people so this is actually one of our
earlier work
so this is an office at mitc sale and
you see my students standing in the
middle of the office now our device is
not even in the same office it's going
to monitor him from the adjacent office
behind this big arrow where you see the
device is behind the wall so we're going
to modulate monitoring him from the
adjacent office now the sweat dots here
that you see where my my cursor is this
red dot is where the device thinks that
he is so as he moves you can see that
the red dot is tracking him
and you can see that we are tracking his
movement from the adjacent office from
behind the wall very accurately he
doesn't have any device on himself it's
purely based on how his movement is
changed in the electromagnetic waves
around him
now of course whenever we we do such a
uh a design we can pair it with a gold
standard in the case of motion we can
pair it with something called vicon
motion capture room and we can ensure
that we have an accuracy that is 89.7
so when we when we do this we started
thinking okay what can we do is being
able to monitor people accurately in
their motion and we discovered that
actually if you can get gauge speed it's
very important for a variety of diseases
so
one of the things that i have to tell
you this is very different from being
from having a fitbit because fitbit just
monitor your acceleration so it doesn't
matter your exact gate and it doesn't
know where you are so cannot get exact
gate speed it just get acceleration
while here we are getting your gate
speed and that actually is a metric that
is used typically even in approval of
drugs for parkinson's for huntington's
for ataxia multiple sclerosis it is also
a predictor of exacerbation in diseases
like chf and copd
now we can with this like smarter wi-fi
like box in the home we can get it 24 7
without asking people to wear wearables
or to uh
worry about charging devices at all and
even through walls so we started asking
what else can we get like can we just
get something that is different uh from
just motion
so one of the things that is very
particularly interesting to me is sleep
because i i have problems with sleep so
we started looking at okay can we get
sleep and i'm sure many of you guys are
thinking yeah i can understand maybe
she's like getting the motion from sleep
so that's that would be a metric of
assessing sleep based on ectography so
when somebody moves you say that they
are not asleep when they are static you
say that they are asleep
but it turns out that we can get
something more deep than just movement
so when you go to sleep your brain waves
change and you enter different stages
awake light sleep deep sleep and rapid
eye movements
now these sleep stages are of course
underlying a variety of there are of
course they are very important for sleep
disorders and perhaps you know that one
in every three people in the u.s has
sleep problems so it's very important to
understand these sleep stages for sleep
disorders but actually it turned out
that sleep stages are important for a
variety of diseases just think about
something like depression for example so
intuitively we know that when you have
mood disorders your sleep get disturbed
but it turned out that also like the
stream stage here is very important for
depression because one of the things
that happens during depression is that
rem starts happening too early during
sleep
so today if you want to get sleep
staging you send someone to a sleep lab
like this they put all of these
electrodes on his head and body and they
asked the person to sleep like this
now of course it's very hard to sleep
with all of these sensors on one on
one's body but also you can imagine like
you cannot do this every night you might
be able to do it one night or two nights
but you can't really continuously do
this
now let me show you how we monitor sleep
so this is our device it transmits very
low power wireless signal analyzes the
reflection using machine learning and
speed cells the sleep stages throughout
the night so what you see here this
graph is something that is called a
hypnogram for every 30 second it tells
you which sleeps which sleep stage the
person is in so it can be like here in
deep sleep or awake etc
and now of course as i said for every
for every health metric we compared to
the gold standard in the case of sleep
staging
we compared to something called psg
and here you see the confusion matrix
and you can see that our accuracy is on
the order of like uh 80
accuracy and remember this is 18
accuracy on every 30 second of sleep
so on assessing every 30 seconds of
sleep
so
so it is actually that is comparable to
a sleep lab when you get a sleep
technician to look at the data but i
want to also get a feeling for how how
uh
like what does it mean to get this 80
accuracy in sleep staging
so let me show you here on the x-axis
this is the time uh
like you see like zero is midnight 1 am
2 am on the y-axis you see the sleep
stages and you see a a prediction of the
sleep staging using psg and we said this
is a gold standard in medicine and
emerald prediction which is our device
using just like this wireless signal
reflected of someone of someone's body
and we you can see that this person went
to sleep around midnight here and he was
asleep until 2a uh sorry he was awake
until 2 a.m
and then around 2 a.m he fell asleep so
he moved from uh
from like uh awake to light sleep
and then he uh he had an excursion into
deep sleep and then again woke up again
around 230 was awake for about an hour
until 360 and then fell asleep again and
then went to deep sleep so you see like
each one of these is is a sleep cycle so
one sleep cycle second sleep cycle third
sleep cycle four sleep cycle and if you
compare the two graphs you see that we
are very like very accurately getting
the sleep uh structure so you can see
very much this is the same sleep for the
same person the only differences are
these this region like this when the
sleep technician is looking at the data
and is saying okay like 30 seconds i'm
saying light sleep then 30 seconds deep
sleep like c you see machine learning
model likes to consolidate this kind of
period so it just consolidated these
things into one sleep stage
but it is quite accurate
now another thing is uh we can monitor
breathing so this person is sitting like
you guys and like what you see on the
screen is his inhales exhales we ask him
to hold his breath and you see the
signal stays at the steady level because
he exhaled he did not inhale
and again for everything we compare with
the gold standard in this case it is a
fta approved uh device uh it's like a
belt that the person wears on their body
and that belt is uh going to give you
the respiration
now i want to zoom in on this signal
this is the same respiration signal what
you see here is the inhales and the
exhales and you see these blips on the
signal these small blades at the
beginning we thought that this is noise
on the signal but it turned out actually
that we we are able to get his heart
beats so ima imagine we are able to get
the pulsing of the blood from this
person without touching him purely
because it changes the pulsing of the
blood changes the electromagnetic waves
around her
so
with all of these signals we can get all
of that stuff imagine sleep movement
breathing in heartbeats without touching
the person and even from behind the wall
so how does it work how can we how how
come we are able to get all of those
things
so if you think about it when you
transmit a wireless signal of course we
all know that wireless signal to reverse
walls on occlusions
and they reflect off the human body
because our bodies are full of water so
some of these minute reflections come
back to our device now
if you think about it like we all know
this very basic equation distance equal
to reflection time multiplied by the
speed of light electromagnetic waves
travel at the speed of light so we all
know the speed of light so if we can
measure the time it took the signal to
go back and forth we can track the
distance of this person so we can track
the movement of this person
so so this is a very uh simple principle
and in fact this is a principle
underlying radar this is like basically
when you when you think about how we
track uh object in the sky using a radar
it is based on these simple principle
however uh
when you when you start thinking about
that you say okay so i need the
reflection time how do i measure
reflection time
so one way to measure a reflection time
is to organize your uh transmitted
signal in something in in uh in a way
that is called fmcw so let me explain
this
so you can transmit a signal
where the time and the frequency have
linear relationship with each other so
the frequency of the signal changes
linearly with time now when this signal
reflects off some object
you will get a received signal and the
distance between in time here is equal
to the reflection time
but this reflection time is related to
the change in frequency at any point in
time between the transmitted and
received signal because you chose your
signal to be where the frequency changes
linearly into time
so you can get the reflection time using
a very simple equation by dividing the
difference in frequency taking fourier
transform
transform basically and dividing the
difference in frequency by the slope of
the signal that you transmitted and you
get the time
and from that remember you can now you
know the time you can multiply by the
speed of the flight so you know the
distance
so are we done
unfortunately it is not that simple
so uh this is this is how we did our
work but if if it were only just
this we would have done this long a long
time ago
now the problem with this is that humans
and all the environment that human live
in is much more complex than the sky and
having one object in the sky so let me
just show you this
so
if you go back and you understand you
analyze our problem we have a person in
in the environment and the radio signal
not only reflects of our human body
actually it reflects of everything of
the table the wall the screen the
computer everything so and not only it
reflects of these objects but it bounces
around from one object to the other so
you get these secondary reflections
so instead like if just the signal
reflecting of medina now the signal is
gonna bounce off me and then bounce off
the wall then off the the screen of my
tv and then go back to the to the device
and now all of these objects starts
moving with me
and so you get so many fictitious target
and instead of getting just this one
single person you get just a mess of
signals and this is why it's not that
simple to just take a radar principles
and apply them to people and minute
motions like the pulsing of one's blood
so this is this is a good starting point
to use radar but it's not the full story
so here you get something called
multi-pass effect so the question
becomes how do we extract the human body
from this massive signal and remember i
just i don't just need to know where the
where this person is i want health
metric i want to know when the person is
in realm versus deep sleep these are not
motion this is something very different
so how do i do this
and the answer is that we use a neural
network that are customized for uh radio
signals
so i'm not gonna get into the details of
this but for for the just general
audience i'm sure all of you guys have
seen neural network but instead of
taking images of audio signal we take
radio signal we'll push it in a custom
neural network of course this is just
like a an illustration but then the
question that we asked at the end of
this neural network we asked questions
about the health of the person so
basically predict for me from using this
radio signal whether this person is
awake asleep uh
what is their movement what is their
respiration all of that stuff
so
so this is at a very very high level and
i'm happy to to answer the question i
just want to talk a bit about the kind
of challenges that you face when you
deal with this are different from just
operating your network on images or on
uh text like nlp so one of the big
problem is that we face is how do you
generalize to a new home let's say that
i took my device and i trained with dina
signal and dina's home
david chris all of those people i need
now to take it to a new person let's say
that we take it to chevy's home and we
want an amount of chef he is asleep so
the device never seen shafi before and
never seen her environment
so we want to be able to generalize to
chef his home without asking shafi to
train again with the device
so so in this case we call these like uh
let's say uh dina and uh so
like some of these subset of z people
with their source domain and we want to
generalize to a target domain now the
biggest problem was doing this i just
told you that radio signal depends on
the environment it reflects off
everything in the environment to flex of
people and there are
bad the walls there like whatever so
it's going to be very different from one
environment to the other so one of the
biggest issues that we face is how do
you remove extraneous information
irrelevant to the task from the signal
and leave only the information that is
relevant to the task
and this is even much more complex than
just an image because if you think about
an image you will have like one one uh
photodiode on the image would be just
part of either like from one object like
each photo diode has one object but here
even every single time sample of the
signal might have reflections for
multiple objects at the same time so let
me uh answer shafi's question jeffy you
have uh your hand raised
yes
my question was on the previous slide
when you were uh
showing the picture of the normal net so
are you gonna get your labels from the
state-of-the-art benchmarks
am i going to get labels from what so
for example uh you have a signal and you
have
in your training stage uh you have some
information about whether parts of the
signal or the 30 seconds windows were
associated with a certain type of sleep
so you're getting that from the
uh state-of-the-art devices
i see so
actually you are asking a very important
question that's one of the challenges so
how do you get the ground truth for
these tasks so uh like typically people
like when
in images or in nlp they train by giving
that signal to humans and say label my
signal say this is a cat picture this is
a dark picture i cannot give my signal
to someone and say look
tell me what the chef he was in light
sleep versus deep sleep during this time
no human would know or uh from the radio
signal how to analyze this
so that so that's a big challenge and
one of the thing here is that depending
on the task we have to find uh a uh
synchronized with with a system that has
the ground tools and have the rf signal
synchronized with that system but
every task has a different ground to
system that we need to synchronize with
and also in the case of the uh if the
sleep for example that i showed we just
we went to mgh here like uh we put our
devices in their sleep lab we
synchronize with with their system and
then we we get the answer from their
system and then we we map it to the
answer in the rf signal and for other
things we we always have like this is
one of the biggest things is how to do
this
and one of the the very interesting
things that we are working on now is can
we actually do self-supervision from the
radio signal and how do we do
self-supervision from radio signals
because on one hand it's easy to put an
antenna and just collect radio signal if
we can do this that would be very
interesting
on the other hand actually radio signals
like you know that when you see image
you know the type of information that
exists in an image so we know images
like capture whatever the light that we
see with our eyes so it doesn't have
more information than typically you
would see with a very good eyesight
but we don't really know all the
information that exists in radio signals
so there might be some information that
even
we haven't thought that they exist in
radio signal and if radio signal can
learn from themselves
then
they can extract things that we don't
even know exist and i'm going to get
back to this point later when i told
when i show you how we diagnose
parkinson's disease
okay so so but this is this is very
relevant question and i'm not going to
answer like how do we do these things uh
i try to keep this at a high level so
that it's not um it's accessible to a
general audience but happy to answer
questions so in the case of how do we
generalize for example we design a
particular conditional discriminator and
we can prove that this discussion we can
modulate and prove that that conditional
discriminator for example uh in the in
equilibrium it removes exactly the
extraneous information that leaves the
useful information
but there are other challenges actually
we just touch
touch on some of these challenges uh for
example data labeling how do we label
radio signals this is one of the
challenges uh we just talked to shafi
about it uh how do we learn without
label we touch on this and there are in
in machine learning there are ways to
learn without labels like contrastive
learning but they are very dedicated for
images and nlp you can't just take them
as they are and extend them to radio
signal and one of the things to think
about particularly not just radio signal
like medical data for example all of
this new modality how do you learn from
them without labels
uh the other thing is how do you
separate physiological signals from
multiple people so i showed you one
person but actually we can extend to a
variety of people in the environment and
uh
but basically uh we we do this with our
with our devices and finally how do you
do domain generalization and transfer
learning i'm happy to talk about all of
that if you ask me question about it but
let's uh let's focus uh let me show you
a bit what we can do
so let's go back to this uh to this
figure here i showed you that we can
track the movement of this person but
one of the things that was bothering me
when i was working with my student i
said okay look i mean we get this dot
but i look at this dot i don't know
whether he's standing or sitting i know
his location but i just
cannot tell whether he's standing or
sitting or what is he doing in that
location
and then when he was moving like
remember like he was moving you see this
dot sliding you don't know whether he
advanced with his sweat
right foot or left foot
so now fast forward this is as i said
one of our earlier results so let's fast
forward and let me show you what we can
get today from radio signals behind a
wall
okay so here you have what you see
the big frame is what the way your
signal sees
this is what our device these skeletons
is extracted by our device this uh this
rgb here just so that you can see what
is happening inside the room
so i'm going to play the video for you
and look at these skeletons and whether
they are tracking through the wall the
people inside the room
so you see when he sits on a chair and
now we can actually know that he's
sitting on a chair not just his location
when he stands up we know he's stood up
when he moves with his right foot we
know that it is the right foot versus
the left foot
so all of this is
all of that information imagine we can
extract from radio signals through walls
and that would not be possible without
these neural networks as i mentioned
here
okay so here you see more people these
are five people and so that i showed i'm
showing you that we can work with
multiple people it's not necessarily
that we just have one person in the
environment
i want to show you also that we can get
the actions of people so here what you
see so the skeleton at the top from the
radio signal and he's emulating combing
his hair and you can see the skeleton
also comes with his hair
so he's moving he's going to emulate a
few things so he's immunity and drinking
you see clearly he's a skeleton drinks
oh so he's gonna try to put some stuff
in his pocket you see the skeleton is
acting the same way as his acting
so
imagine being able to track through all
these actions of people just purely
through the wireless signal
without a camera without any
visual access
now over the last three years we have
been working with doctors in a variety
of diseases parkinson's disease
alzheimer's are aware of diseases such
as fshd
dermatitis
immune diseases like atopic and
dermatitis cones and
copd also pulmonary disease and finally
also we worked with covet of course and
i want to show you some of the results
from the from actual patients and real
diseases like what i showed you earlier
are my students and getting something in
the labs this is one of the things that
i learned the hard way
uh as academicians we we try to set up
things in the lab and show that they
work but actually when you go to the
right to to to the real world the amount
of uncertainty is huge and it's just
completely different
so let me show you what we can do with
real patients so this is our device so
as you can see it is very non-obtrusive
it sits on the wall and just like
you can have you can completely forget
about its existence
so i'm going to show you first some of
the results with parkinson patients and
this is from a study it's a it's a large
parkinson center called the udall center
funded by nih and it's a collaboration
with dr ray dorsey from the university
of rochester medical school
so let's start by showing you just uh
let's focus on this patient first so
this is a patient who happens to live in
an assisted living community so here you
see this uh green rectangle is our
device and you see this blue line is two
hours of movement from this person so we
see he's moving between his bed his
chair so here is like a kitchen area he
has a microwave he can cook some stuff
he enters the bathroom he comes back he
like all of that stuff says this is
about two hours of his movements
and what we do is that we put this
device with with these patient parkinson
patients and we try it first to
understand their life understand their
health completely passively so let me
let me explain this graph to you so
first this graph is for this patient so
this is the patient and this is uh
our understanding of his life just
purely by analyzing the radio signal so
every circle here is one day of his life
the innermost circle this one
is the first day of the study the
outermost circle is the last day of the
study zero here at the top is midnight
and 12 at the bottom is noon time
so let's uh let's look at this uh this
graph so first let's look at the blue
blue refers to the time when he's asleep
in bed so you can see at the beginning
of the study like here near the inner
circle the blue is very fragmented
so his sleep is really bad like just
he's hardly getting any sleep
and as the study continues this blue is
starting to consolidate and his sleep is
improving drastically
so
so parkinson actually is a disease where
sleep gets impacted badly and you can
see this effect on this patient
now another thing that you see is this
green all over this place it's just like
the the whole graph is green and green
refers to the time he's sitting on a
chair so here like if i go back you see
that he likes to sit on this chair so he
wakes up sits on this chair and you look
at this graph and you see green all over
the place so this is a person who wakes
up sits on a chair and this is virtually
all that he does with his life
so this is of course it's very bad
because i mean for particularly older
people like if you are very sedentary
that leads to many exhaust solvation in
variety and of comorbidities
another thing that you see is this cone
of
yellow around 8 a.m in the morning so
you see where i'm moving my cursor this
is a cone of yellow here so yellow
refers to the time he goes to the
bathroom
so one of the things that when when me
and my students looked at this graph
which is like why why is he like waking
up around 3 4 a.m sitting on a chair
until exactly 8 a.m in the morning and
then at 8 00 am he does
his showering and toileting like
all of us or the majority of us we wake
up we typically go and do our showering
and toileting why is this person waiting
until 8 a.m in the morning exactly to go
to the bathroom
so it like when the doctor looked at
this he said oh wow this is interesting
that it turns out that basically what is
happening here is that remember like
this person lives in assisted living
community
so at 8 00 am the health worker comes so
this person sits on the chair waiting
for somebody to come around 8am to help
him with his showering and toileting
and
people didn't realize how much he's
dependent on this person but when you
when you look at the graph like this the
doctor was saying this is really like
bad because it means that this person
cannot do the basic things of showering
and toileting on his own
now another thing that you can see here
is a cone if white between 17 and 18. so
you see this corn of white here refers
to the time that he's outside the
coverage area of the radio signal so
when he leaves his unit we cannot see
him and we don't track him so we see we
see this white corn
and this is between 17 and 18 so between
5 pm to 6 pm so every day almost every
day between 5 and 6 pm he leaves his
room
and this is because he really wants to
have dinner with the rest of the people
in the assisted living community
so you see this ritual but you see that
on a very specific day he actually comes
back early like here where i'm moving my
cursor so this person on this day he
didn't feel well he had actually to come
back early
so
just by putting a smarter wi-fi like box
in his room without asking him or asking
anyone for any information or any
wearables we just have a whole vision of
his life his ability to do his basic
toileting showing his sleep his ritual
and also when he he had to break this
ritual because he was not feeling well
so all of this information is passive
now another thing that is really
interesting particularly when you are
monitoring people who have diseases is
to actually check whether you are
confirming the gold standard like how
the doctors assess the severity of
parkinson's so here what you see on the
x-axis is something called the mdsu pdrs
so all that you have to know for this
presentation is that the mdsu pdrs is uh
measures the severity of parkinson's so
basically 100 is much more severe it's
actually pretty severe parkinson's than
like for example more severe than 40. so
this is measure of the severity of
parkinson and to assess the mdsupdrs
you typically have to bring people to
the clinic and like the clinician will
spend three hours on average to assess
this test it takes a very long time so
what you can see is that in the home
just by measuring the gauge speed of
people every dot here is one percent we
can assess something that is highly
correlated to the gold standard in
assessing parkinson's disease
another thing that was very interesting
is to be able to capture response to
medications
so again for people who don't know about
parkinson's disease i mean parkinson's
disease is a motion disorder like i'm
sure all of you have seen people with
parkinson and have seen that they have
tremor and they but what the kind of uh
of medications that we have for
parkinson's is called levadopa
and unfortunately it's a medication that
controls the symptoms but actually it
does not cure the disease so it's only
controlling the symptom and one of the
hardest things for for a doctor is to
try to adjust the dose of levodopa for
the patient so that the patient stays at
a steady level like they they actually
get enough levodopa so that they they
control the symptoms but not too much
because like any drug is a poison so you
don't want to give too much of that drug
to the patient but just enough to
control the symptom
so what i'm going to show you here on
the x-axis is the hour of the day so 4
means 4 a.m
like 14 is 2 p.m so you see 24 hours on
the x-axis
on the y-axis is the average gate speed
of a particular patient
and let me plot this graph for you so
this is a graph that we it's typically
is used in medicine and it's called the
box plot and
i just want you to look at the red line
so the red line is the average gate
speed of this person for every uh 15
minute sorry for every half an hour in
the day so you just see it like track
the red line so interestingly so you see
that the red line goes up and down so
the ability of this person the gate of
this person is not steady it's just
going up and down and one thing that is
interesting now you just can plot on top
of this the medications so this person
actually takes his medication around 6
30
in the in the in the morning and you can
see immediately as he takes his
medication his gait speed starts going
up so he can move much much faster now
and then after some point the medication
effect starts wearing off and you see
the gate speed just going down and then
he takes his second dose of levodopa and
now the gate speed again starts going up
and then after about two hours the
effective medication starts wearing off
he takes another dose and another dose
every time he takes a dose he he
his met his he takes the medication his
gaze improve and then after sometimes
the medication wears off and you see
like the dipping
and that's very interesting because
actually this is not a good behavior
like you don't want the person to have
these like ups and downs in their motor
symptoms this fluctuation is bad and
impact both the functionality of the
patient and even their ability to
interact with people so you would like
this the sweat line to be steady
throughout the day and then go down in
the evening when the patient is about to
go to sleep so by knowing this now the
doctor can adjust the dose of medication
to try to keep this line as a straight
line
but without this they have no idea what
is going on with the patient
so let me show you our last
result which is actually one of the most
interesting thing that i found this is
we haven't published this yet we uh it's
very recent and this is a collaboration
with uh university of rochester uh
mass general hospital and mayo clinic
so can ai detect parkinson's from
nocturnal breathing can i just diagnose
someone using machine learning
uh just by looking at their breathing
now again we all know that parkinson is
a motor symptoms like it's like we
diagnose parkinson based on tremor based
on movements but the problem when you
diagnose parkinson based on movement is
that we end up diagnosing parkinson five
to ten years after that actually the
disease has started
so if you want to diagnose parkinson
early we need to find something else to
use to diagnose parkinson
and one of the things that we started
thinking about is can we actually use
this radio signal and we know that we
can get easily the breathing of patients
uh so can we just look at whether the
machine learning model would know
whether somebody has parkinson's from
their breathing
and so this is our device and we just
take the breathing of the of the person
we train the machine learning model that
is specific for this task and let me
show you the results
so
we can actually from the wireless signal
and by transforming the wireless system
to an intro
to a uh
like a middle stage interpretation that
is breathing we can actually with
accuracy that is about 90 percent auc 92
to be able to tell whether somebody has
parkinson or not
so that's that's actually very
interesting because today you can never
give breathing to a doctor and say can
you diagnose whether the patient has
parkinson's
so not only we are training models to do
what doctors do
we want to train models to do things
that doctors today cannot do
and extracting new information that
otherwise potentially is infeasible
and one of the things so now that we
know that wireless signals from
nocturnal breathing can can diagnose
parkinson's we started asking the
question can we diagnose that somebody
has parkinson before actually a doctor
diagnoses them so can we actually
predict and then check after a few years
that the person indeed got parkinson's
so unfortunately like we don't have so
many people from whom we have signals
before uh like many years before they
got diagnosed so but we have very few
patients that we have signals we have
their breathing about five years
we have their breathing five years
before they were diagnosed for
parkinson's disease so let me show you
this graph so in blue you see the the
patients who eventually
in in five years down the road they they
were telling us during the visit that
they have parkinson's in land you see
people who never got diagnosed for
parkinson and you see this yellow line
is the threshold of our model and you
can see that the model actually can tell
like for about 75 percent of the people
that eventually got diagnosed with
parkinson's that actually they kind of
like looking like parkinson's patients
while the people who never got parkinson
the model is sure about them that they
don't have parkinson's
this is very promising because i mean
this is of course very very initial
results so we we need to do many more
tests with much larger population than
this to be able to confirm it but it is
very promising because it would be one
way to try to detect parkinson's early
and if we have any chance to develop
drugs for parkinson's disease you need
to be able to detect it early
i want to show you actually i'm going to
uh because of time i'm going to uh jump
quickly and just uh
jump to this part
so
one of the things that we also did is to
be able to monitor covet 19 with our
devices and this is a study with harvard
medical school with dr ipsec varia
and we uh we were asked when uh
probably all of you remember the time
when in your in retirement homes there
was a a breakout of cover it and many
people died uh
during that time people in retirement
homes came to us and asked us to use our
device because it's completely contact
class so there is no danger of cantation
so they asked us to monitor people with
covet to check whether they are
recovering because remember like when
you have somebody who has corporate they
have to quarantine and be alone and if
that person is somebody who is old they
have co-morbidity they have memory
problems and alzheimer's it is very uh
dangerous that you are quarantining them
and you don't know whether they are
recovering smoothly or not
so we started monitoring these covert
patients and we were looking for the
recovery and whether the recovery is a
smooth one or not
so let me show you our results so this
is breathing from a patient who has
covered and you see on april 7 the
breathing rate is about 23 breaths per
minute
four days later on april 11 you can see
that the breathing rate went down to 18
breaths per minute so as the patient is
recovering like his breathing is getting
back to the baseline in fact for this
patient the breathing is the baseline is
pretty much near 18 breaths per minute
so breathing one of the things that
happens during covered of course
corporate affects the the respiratory
system and you get the breathing
elevated and then as a person recover
they the breathing goes back to normal
another thing that happens is mobility
so covert causes a humongous amount of
fatigue
and what you see here this
green dot is a patient you can see the
movement on april 8th versus april 11.
and you can see on april 11 the patient
is much more agile moving much faster
and also uh more balanced so moving from
the in both cases moving from the chair
to the bathroom
now of course
not all cases are uh
like everything is fine sometimes
actually we see uh for example this is a
patient and you see this is actually the
breathing of the patient this is very
abnormal breathing that we see in this
patient and instead like remember the
breathing the inhales exhale the noise
sinusoidal movement that i showed you
earlier so here here you see that this
patient has
both the magnitude of each breast is
very irregular and also like some
breasts
is much wider both the magnitude and the
frequency of the breathing is changing
from one breast to the next
very abnormal breathing
it turned out that breathing actually is
a very important metric for covet and if
we actually have the ability to monitor
breathing we can get much more
information than otherwise so let me
show you this graph
so this is a case for a patient who got
rehospitalized because of covalent
and
let me explain this so each curve here
is a histogram of breathing so this and
it is one day so you see for example the
first day is april or eighth and you see
the histogram of breathing so you can
see that it's like the tip here the mood
is uh slightly below 20 breaths per
minute
so every every one of these histogram is
one day so you see at the beginning the
patient is breathing weight is
decreasing going slowly toward the
baseline and then on april 14 suddenly
the breathing rate jumps up
and the patient in fact on that day
ended up in the hospital for for
breathing problem
so you can see like the breathing got
really changed and then the patient
actually you see like here the patient
spent one week in the hospital from
april 14 until april 21st and then when
she came back she again like if you
monitor the breathing you see the
breathing rate goes back to normal
gradually
and eventually the patient recovered and
um
was fine
but when we monitored like in our
population we are able to see three
types of patients so patients who
actually uh
are symptomatic and they get problems
like the patient that got
re-hospitalized and you can see from the
breathing that the breathing was moving
gradually and then jumped up
and so those are people who have
problems with recovery then you see
another type of patients
who are symptomatic but everything goes
smoothly so patients recover and
while the patient is suffering but
eventually everything moves in the right
direction and the patient recovers
without uh ending up being hospitalized
and then finally you see these
asymptomatic patients that we all have
heard about who have no symptoms like
they are positive for covet but they
have no symptoms
and again their breathing shows that
very clearly and uh we see it also in
the others and in the other metrics that
we mentioned
so this gets me to the end of this
presentation so really what i presented
to you is a new way of think of thinking
about
getting health monitoring but instead of
like relying on wearable which are nice
and good but they are limited we are
talking about this new notion of the
invisibles can we just change the
environment so that it can monitor our
health our well-being without wearables
without charging devices without wearing
devices just have this ambient
intelligence this uh invisible
intelligence in the environment
now before ending i want just to add one
thing of course privacy and security are
very very important and we are seeing
people through walls and getting their
vitals without uh through all so so
privacy is a big
thing that we work on and uh we do
address privacy both in terms of
technology in terms of designing methods
that would prevent access to information
that for people who are not authorized
to do it and
like physical methods not like just
based on cryptography because i can take
that device and turn it and face the
wall uh start monitoring my colleague
here through the wall but that will not
be dealt with with crypto you need new
ways of understanding security and
privacy and also through of course irb
every single study that we do
we do with a uh
by getting uh imb approval checking
ethics and getting informed consent from
patients and individuals so i'll stop
here and take any questions
so there are questions first of all in
the q a
and after that i have a bunch of
questions but i'm going to let somebody
else out so do you see the q a
oh maybe i can read it too so the first
question is can this method be extended
to visualize what happens in the
cell mean in the body like ultrasound
can we even detect what rna is being
transcribed inside the cell
so so i think so there are two things
that are different so can it be extended
to to track what happens inside the body
versus can it be done on the cell lab at
the cell level and i think the
so the answer is that we need more
research along that line so i can tell
you for example one of the things that
one the first extension to within the
body one of the things that we were very
interested in is can we like for example
get the vitals of uh if a baby in in
in the womb
and also getting information from inside
the body and we didn't do it with babies
but we did it with a uh
a an embryo like a turkey that is inside
an egg so we started monitoring a turkey
baby inside his egg and we we were able
to get his respiration before actually
he was he he hatched and eventually he
hatched and we had to deal with the
turkey and sea cell chef
we called him tim which is the the
inverse of mit him
and then i had a turkey running in my
lab
so then that part of the study stopped
and uh then going back to the cell stuff
actually is very very interesting
because i
depend like you i think to go and
monitor things inside the cell there is
an interesting
way to try to think about it one has to
go to frequencies that are much higher
so that you can get very small
wavelengths because you are interested
in very small movements and changes so
that is possible it gets it just needs
more uh it's a different research and uh
but there is an opportunity there
the next question um was uh i say
do they need sleeping to detect this so
this was 11 47 so i assumed that had
something to do with the parkinson
uh breathing
uh
i think uh
sarah if you're online maybe you can
let's assume
yeah so uh
so can can they need to do they need to
sleep
so sleep i think it was part of your
talk when you were talking about uh the
breathing
uh frequency for the parkinson patients
and the question was
whether they need to be sleeping for
this detection
yeah so so
we do it during sleep for for two
reasons so one thing is that
basically when you go to sleep so
breathing and many of our vitals they
change drastically throughout the day
not because of our health like when i
talk of course my breathing is
modulating my sleep so that has nothing
to do with my health it's really has to
do with what i'm saying
so so it's
one of the things that i learned is that
sleep is really
very interesting normalization of the
body so you want to get like a resting
state so that you can
compare across people compare across
days so so this is why we we like to use
the nocturnal breathing and nocturnal
information so we did it with nocturnal
breathing the other thing was
parkinson's so
independent of our work there was there
were multiple studies that look at eeg
of people during sleep and they also
showed that
it's different from from from the from
the from normal individual and
particularly different they see
differences during them and during the
transition from awake to sleep
so what we what we saw in our model
although we are using breathing not eeg
but it focuses on these periods for the
parkinson's patient the transition
between sleep and awake and how it
happens
the next question is while this
application offers great promise for
health care the technology described
also offers unprecedented tool for
continuous inexpensive
and superstitious invasion of privacy
okay as you've developed the ml models
and associated hardware have you
considered complementary methods to
throughout such monitoring is there a
straightforward way for individuals to
confound the models or swamp the
relevant radio signals
yeah so this is really interesting
because as like one of the issues that
when
even like when we started looking at it
of course i mean just the pure fact that
you are seeing people through walls
without even having them to wear
something on their body you immediately
think about privacy
and i think that is really interesting
space about
privacy and like
method for privacy for for that used
physical actions so one of the things
that we designed for example is we
started using something like challenge
response so in challenge response
challenge response of course something
that we use in computer science when
somebody wants to access something to
prove that they are human so like they
give you this picture and you have to
like count i don't know like how many
subpictures have
a traffic light
or know what is in the picture so so
this uh you can imagine because our
device can monitor how people move in
space so the challenge response here is
a physical challenge with responses the
device saying okay dina if you are
saying you want me to monitor you and
this is you just take a step now to the
right now take two steps like you can
have this random challenge response that
is based on physical movement and if the
person cannot satisfy the challenge and
not respond to the challenge then you
say okay so you know you are asking me
to monitor this maybe someone else i'm
not gonna do it
and then you also ask them to walk the
space that they are requesting to
monitor to to to prove that they have
access to it now there are other things
that one could do also on the jamming
level like for example you can always
jam any radio signal to prevent it from
being uh accessible
but that require generating signals uh
what uh
so so so there are many questions in
that domain i think it is both like it
has to be addressed both with technology
but also i think it's very important to
be addressed with policy like as i said
for anything independent of these
security and privacy issues there are
ethical issues when you are collecting
any health information and one has to go
through iob one has to have informed
consent all of that stuff
so in terms of jamming is this similar
to what you had with jamming for the
[Music]
the devices that were implanted uh
so you had a necklace i remember that
could jam
of people
people trying to maybe disrupt your
heart tribulator
or something like that right
well i'm quite impressed that you still
remember yes
yes it's along the same line
okay the next question was um
when you uh
[Music]
when you uh talked about separating
different people
um there was a you said that you have
some uh work on that and i was wondering
um
whether that was whether you knew i
guess a two-state that just
you see there are five people and you
could tell there are five people
and what signal belongs to each person
do you know who those people are in
advance is it like
supervised that way yeah yeah so this is
interesting so it's like a difference
between separating people and
identifying people so we we have none
work on identification and what we do is
not identification but we identification
so basically uh my interest is really
not to know who's who but is like okay
to be able to tell that this is the same
person again and again and again and
then if the person at the first time
this is introduced at the patient then i
know that this is the patient i don't
actually want to know who the other
people are
because i don't want to identify them i
only want to identify my patient from
the rest of the people and we did work
in on this this problem actually it's
equivalent or analogous to a problem
that exists in machine vision it's
called we id
and we can re-identify people from their
wireless signals
so i guess
my question was how does it relate to uh
sound separation because i know there's
a lot of work on sound separation and it
sounded more similar to that and and i i
guess it leads to
suppose you had a system for sound
separation can you use it in conjunction
with your uh
your system for movement
yeah so yeah so actually i mean sound
and and radio and all of these signals
are just like
they're all waves and there is so much
that is
similar like in fact i was saying like
it is like originally like it's the
foundation is in radar but sauna is very
much similar to radar so uh so sound
separation is
kind of there are similarities but there
are some differences so similarities
first like basically you can beam your
signal whether it's sound or ultrasound
or rf you can beam your signal so that
you can separate voxels in space from
each other
and you can also design that signal like
that fmcw that frequency that changes
linearly with time that i talked about
also gives you distance in fact because
rf is is is a complex number it's not
it's like it has a wave it kind of like
gives you distance because basically
depending on the phase of the signal
because it rotates with distance you
have information about distance that you
typically don't see in in
the visible light thing for example so
you do you do have direction from the
from the beam and you have a distance
that your leverage that is related to
the wave and the fmcw
uh
so so that also shared with with sound
right uh the other thing that that the
problem was rf bounces a lot of the
walls and the bouncing effect is
slightly different from how sound
bounces and the wavelengths is different
in size so there are certain things the
and like the absorbance and the the
material and all of that stuff slightly
different so there are so many relations
uh or similarities between radio waves
and sound waves and all waves in general
so you actually uh brought me to my next
question which is uh
about bouncing uh in walls so could you
use this in an outside in a different
environment in water
let's say or when you don't have walls
but you have other mediums that you're
yeah so so outside yeah no problem in
fact outside is easier in the sense that
it is uh they have you have fewer things
for the signal to bounce off and create
a big mass
uh in the body actually it's really
interesting because uh
rf signal uh says the decay of rf signal
in the human body is exponential
so it decays very very quickly so you
can't get
what we call deep tissue unless you have
a very different design to
to to get deep tissue now
there are certain things that you can do
to get deep tissue but
it's not as simple as inside the body
it's just yet another medium because the
the the signal dies exponentially and so
very very quickly you are dealing with
very very minor signal
uh another question here oops some of
the questions disappeared uh
wait wait
it was uh thank you for great talk
everybody says thank you i didn't read
those but um
a
curious about the nocturnal breathing
induced rf signal generation mechanism
so they're curious about the
mechanism i don't know
that's a question
so it says thank you for great talk
curious about the nocturnal breathing
induced rf signal generation mechanism
the nocturnal breathing in juice okay so
so basically like at the higher level
what is happening here
we so we had
so it is the model of course is a neural
network model is a complex multi-neural
network model one of the biggest problem
that you are you would face when you are
trying to deal with modality with a new
modality like a radio signal
particularly modality that is difficult
and you don't have historic data for it
so it's not like we have to collect the
data with the parkinson's patient it's
not like we have his
like i know like signal rf signal from
uh 10 000 parkinson's patient in the
past that doesn't exist so one of the
things that's really important is to
translate into an intermediate
representation for who for which you
have a large amount of signals
so when so that's one very important
thing and we always deal with this issue
and use this as an architectural uh
design principle so in the case of
parkinson's so one of the things that we
have to think about okay so to be able
to run a neural network on parkinson's
detection and actually not only
detection we can even tell the severity
of the disease
we we needed to get data from a large
number of people both who have
parkinson's and who don't have
parkinson's
and we would avoid the lives we can get
100 people but we can't get ten thousand
so what we decided to do is to use
nocturnal breathing because if we do
that then we can go and like find all
the sleep studies
from all of these hospitals so this is
our collaboration with mayo clinic with
mass general with all of these sites
and say okay so we want you your sleep
studies and you want you to go back to
also the the the medical record and see
who has parkinson who doesn't have
parkinson's now we take that data which
has this respiration and we take the
respiration from our device and use that
as an intermediate stage if the if the
design of the model so that the model
can transfer
between the two representations the two
modalities very easily using this
intermediate representation which is
respiration nocturnal breathing
so that's that that's the cornerstone in
the design of the model now of course
there are many other things because i
mean this is a very
weak signal in this test
um
maybe last question uh two questions one
is uh so i i you talked about uh
the issue of medication efficacy and
what level of medication you need
so
i find the connection to depression and
in
medication for depression very
interesting because that seems to me
that we feel that has exploded
uh probably even during covet you know
getting a lot of depression
medication not so much monitoring and
maybe this gives some kind of help for
that did you think about that is there
any research on that
yeah so actually i think depression and
in general what's called mood disorders
are very
very good area where you need something
like this because
first of all i mean
we we have no good biomarkers for these
kind of diseases so having behavioral
biomarker is very important sleep is
it's a platform for all mood disorders
and movement and withdrawal and being
able to see how the patient is moving or
the person is moving whether there is a
withdrawal in their in their actions and
stuff like that so so this is very
interesting we haven't done major
studies like the one that we have done
in other disease areas in depression yet
i i'm very interested i'll just
like typically we work we need a doctor
a specialist when we work in a disease
area who who has the patient who has
access to them but we saw many of the
patients in our other studies
or even healthy individuals not patients
who went through depressive mode and we
see that in their signal in fact the
first time we ran into depression was we
were not doing we were doing sleep
studies we were collecting data about
sleep
and it was a healthy individual a
young
student who nobody would have thought
about depression or anything like that
but it's like basically we saw him
cinemas just like rem is happening too
early is it like is it a mistake in our
device but then the ground truth was
saying the same thing it's like what's
going on and then we started learning
that actually
in one one of the
the thing that happened in depression is
that rem starts happening too early
and uh if you think about depression uh
drugs like there is ssris
which are also called remo present
so so being able to monitor continuously
in the hormonal sleep monitor behavior i
think it's very important for
understanding depression and to send
your relapses into depression
without like
overwhelming the person is like okay
write me a diary every day and
this is exactly the thing that a
depressed person doesn't want to do
and then the other thing that is very
interesting is the drugs for depression
because not everyone the same drug
doesn't work for everyone the same way
and typically it takes long time like
sometimes you put someone on the drug
too long and it's not working for them
so if one could use this information to
very quickly decide whether the drug is
working or not for a patient i think
that would be very helpful so so
depression is a very very interesting
area that i think we can do a lot of
novel work we just need the right doctor
to work with
wow
so
thank you dina uh for an amazing uh talk
and
for your answers and uh
thanks again thanks again for coming
thank you thank you for inviting me and
thank you all and it was a pleasure
thanks fascinating thank you very much
have a nice bye
you